then let me move to the council meetings
uh the high representative joseph bohel
is chairing an informal meeting of
development ministers
in montpellier
in which commissioners oliver valhalla
and utah opilinen take part on behalf of
the commission
ministers will discuss the situation in
ukraine from the development perspective
beyond the current humanitarian crisis
they will also discuss the geopolitical
dimension of our international
cooperation
a press conference with high
representative borrel will take place at
around 2 30 p.m and therefore as usual i
invite you to reserve your questions
related to these topics for the relevant
press conference
with this
we've come to the end of our
announcements and you have the floor
finbar
since i see no hand raised in the press
room we go to you
thank you eric
it's a question perhaps for nabila
related to
china's stance on russia
um this morning foreign minister wang yi
gave his annual
briefing to the media in beijing
in which he said that china's
relationship with russia is rock solid
and he also said china was
was willing to promote negotiation uh
towards a ceasefire
but also
said that
eu-china relations should be considered
separately to eu-russia relations that
there should be no bleed over between
the two so my question is um a what's
the response to the to the beijing
statement that
china's relationship with russia is rock
solid and b
it does the eu believe that there um
there may be some deterioration in its
relationship with china should beijing
not act constructively on the ukraine
situation thank you very much
thank you nabila is actually in
montpellier for the foreign affairs
council related to development but we
have the pleasure of welcoming peter
once again and so i pass him the floor
hi good afternoon well thank you for the
question finn barr you know that high
representative is uh quite frequently in
contact with his chinese counterpart mr
wang yi
and uh this communication continues and
what we are saying to china and
especially in the context of
of the current uh of the current
circumstances of putin's war against
ukraine is that the key is to press
russia to stop this aggression this
unprecedented attack against territorial
integrity and sovereignty of a country
and china has the potential to reach out
to moscow because of the relationship
obviously and we would like china to use
its influence to press for a ceasefire
and to make russia to stop the brutal
unprecedented shelling and killing of
civilians in ukraine when it comes to eu
china relationship you know that this
relationship has been discussed very
often it's multifaceted complex
relationship and we hope that in these
testing times each country which puts
emphasis on respect for rules and
international principles and
international order will do its best to
prevent these atrocities and the and
this war to continue so this is the
framework of our relationship
with china and our engagement right now
as i said hrvp was has been and will be
in touch with his chinese counterpart to
deliver this and to continue discussing
the the relationship between eu and
china of course and also the joint
actions we could do in order to make
this this unjustified aggression to stop
finborough you have a follow-up
yes eric thank you um thank you peter
for the response are you concerned
however um
that china has basically said that the
relationship with russia is rock solid
so whereas on one hand um china is
voicing a willingness to
um to to help negotiate on the other
hand it is voicing tacit support for
moscow um uh secretary of state lincoln
speaking in values this morning said
that beijing's actions on this issue
speak louder than words so i'm wondering
whether it's also an area of concern
for the european union
again our engagement with china
continues and our message to china is
very clear
china
was not among the five countries when
the u.n was voting on putin's war
against ukraine so china abstained so
this is already showing that china is
not among the five isolated countries
which were against this u.n resolution
resolution and this is
reason for us to continue and even step
up our engagement to make sure
to our partners including in china
how important it is to join forces the
civilized community of nations who value
territorial integrity and sovereignty to
join forces to stop this unprecedented
aggression
thank you other questions on foreign
relations for
peter
i only see one hand raised and it is
thomas's so thomas you have the floor
uh i apologize it's a question on
switzerland i don't think it's for peter
it wasn't quick enough in raising my
hand apologies um all right could i say
to the people who are posting comments
um
in the chat please we have a live press
conference here and therefore i'm not
going to be reading out questions that
are
put in writing unless there are
exceptional circumstances for doing so
so we move back to the uh questions
christian
b avenue
[Music]
mercy
the
merci
are there other foreign relations
as they say pure foreign relations
related questions
for
peter today
uh hi now
well i think your question is also on
energy importance go ahead
on
[Music]
catherine
hi is that working it is go ahead
uh so it's i think it's a question for
peter um
there's been obviously very close
cooperation between the us and the eu
over sanctions uh linked to russia's
invasion of ukraine
and
both um
was both a high representative and
secretary of state raised concerns about
the situation in herzegovina and i'm
just wondering if you are considering if
the eu is not considering sanctions
against milorad dodge thank you
peter
well the situation in bosnia herzegovina
is a source of concern for the european
union and we were very uh clear and loud
about it on number of occasions the last
was
the
foreign first council i wanted to say
the last but there were so many over the
last few days so in in january the
foreign affairs council was discussing
bosnia herzegovina again and said that
in order to overcome the political
crisis and also the unilateral
succession is steps by certain actors
the eu is uh ready to employ everything
what we have at our disposal that
includes also the sanctions framework
which is already there since i think
2011.
but as with every decision regarding
sanctions and restrictive measures this
is something for the member states to
decide and agree uh by consensus among
themselves and as you know we are never
commenting these discussions unless uh
until there is an um decision made at
this stage the eu was very clear and
very vocal and uh stressed unanimously
that we
call on all the actors in bosnia
herzegovina
to
end the political crisis to do their
best to restart the proper working of
the country of its institutions and of
course we were very clear in
condemnation of all the unilateral and
secessionist steps which are undermining
the unity sovereignty and territoriality
integrity of bosnia herzegovina again we
are calling on all the actors to behave
constructively and uh we are ready to
deploy all the means and instruments at
our disposals if they want
thank you so grizella your question was
actually on sanctions
so go ahead
but we can't hear you for some reason
your mic seems to be turned on
okay and there's a problem now with your
connection it seems
one last attempt no it's not working
sorry for that
so we'll try to come back to you
afterwards
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
um
tv
free
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello
thank you eric
i'll ask about the
counter sanctions
that russia
[Music]
might impose on on
on eu
where are
the member states and the commission as
well
in in in the initiatives which will be
taken like two or three weeks ago
of
uh facing a such a mentality in in
replacing uh
those kind of uh
uh supplies that could be eventually cut
by by russia
itself on gas and oil as well we have
heard so much talks on coordinating with
other suppliers across the world
especially with the u.s
i'm asking the question for example
because i'm recalling nearly two weeks
cut in 2009
and in such eventually
[Music]
thank you
you have that problem
thanks um so aikram i think your your
question um uh in in so far as concerns
me is where we are with um preparedness
uh for potential interruptions of of
supply uh in our energy supplies
if that does happen and that's a topic
which has been mentioned repeatedly by
by the president by commissioner simpson
in previous weeks there's a
a lot of coordination which has been
going on with the member states to
understand where they stand the
commission has also been doing its own
analysis
of the situation and the you know the
headline message which the president has
repeated
um is that for for this winter cooling
season which we're approaching the end
of
we are rather on the safe side in terms
of the energy supply that we have we
have
interconnections between our member
states meaning that nobody is is
dependent on just one
source of energy or just one supplier
and we've been working as you mentioned
very intensively with alternative gas
suppliers around the world with
different partners look at increasing
lng imports and
pipeline imports and lng imports
actually reached a historic high in in
january providing 10 billion cubic
meters of
of lng gas into europe
and we also of course have gas storage
um gas storage tends to provide quite a
significant share of our heating anyway
throughout the winter
we're currently at just under 30 percent
in terms of the the filling level of gas
storage
in europe um so that's where we stand
for for now um and as i said we're
regularly in contact with all of our
member states to make sure that we're
closely coordinated with them in case of
any
any incidents
hey can you have a follow-up
yes it's it's a logical follow-up
uh what justine said to us now
the deputy chancellor of germany uh said
it like four or five days ago
so my question is
if the member countries
are
prepared already or have made all the
preparations to to face the
eventually
two months cut
uh which could
uh uh be done by russia
where is the obstacle why then the the
eu member concerned that uh switching
off the pipelines themselves first
before putin does it for example
if you are ready to to go ahead and not
feel the consequences no that's uh
you are interpreting uh things um in a
way which is not correct what i think
tina said is that
we are prepared uh for cuts uh
in particular until the end of the
heating season
right and uh who knows if there are cuts
how long they last you say two months
but who knows
how long um cuts would last so
um
you need to check your premise you know
the premise to your question
that's important obviously we have taken
all the measures uh that we could and
continue to take measures that we can
in order to be as resilient as possible
um in the face of a potential of a
potential cut
but
obviously
once if there was a a cut
we would have to see exactly what are
what is the length of it etcetera
etcetera so um it's not as if it's a
black and white uh
scenario
so
this is this is the position that we're
on but again we have um
the heads of cabinet meeting at this
point in time
we will be announcing the agenda later
this afternoon and i'm sure we'll have
the opportunity of coming back to this
tomorrow
okay hello
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
jessica
yeah well look
it's very difficult to manage there are
so many dimensions to uh to the ukraine
situation
that will take your questions as they
come thank you
and yeah just on energy um
the commission president said this
morning she wanted to get rid of
europe's reliance on russian coal um gas
and oil i just want to understand that
um more exactly is the long-term aim to
have zero imports of that nature or just
to dramatically reduce them thank you
look she has said to get rid of
i think to get rid of in english
language is a relatively clear
clear term uh now what she has also said
in her speakings is that this implies
um
two things on the one hand diversifying
well three things in fact
on the one hand diversifying our sources
of
supply of gas be it lng or pipeline gas
from reliable
producers
and secondly what she called re-power eu
which is an acceleration
of our investment in
in renewables
and and thirdly
efforts um
on energy efficiency
now um
what the
what the end result of that
will be
is
a
highly increased
capacity of europe to
[Music]
supply its
its energy away from russia and
to increase the share of homegrown
energy
that is the that is the
objective
okay christian
no
change
hmm
[Music]
who knows what's happening
yep go ahead
yeah red is good
um two questions one is uh red's energy
another one to the
horizon um
the the recent press release um sent out
last week on
on energy uh the question is simply
previously you talked about uh
ensuring supply by for instance
switching lng contracts
uh can we get an update on how many are
actually being switched and whether
something has been redirected to europe
as we speak the other one is relating to
the the corporation on research uh it's
in the press release it's mentioned that
uh
it'll be uh that
that there won't be any new agreements
but also that the existing ones and the
existing projects are being reviewed
could maybe get a little bit more
context on when that review is going to
stop and what's going to happen in the
meantime thank you
okay
tim any updates we can give on swaps uh
no not specifically on on swaps actually
i mean what we've seen so far is is very
much an increase um in supply
you know as driven a little bit by our
conversations a little bit by the market
there the discussions about contract
swaps um we've we've talked about this
with some of our asian partners with
japan and korea is rather in the case
where we would have an interruption of
supply so we haven't
to my knowledge activated any of those
as yet
right on research
yes thanks for the question did we have
published a press release last week um
specifying that uh
um
no new agreements will be uh will be
signed and that everything is under
review as concerns cooperation on
research with russia
um so you know that there is uh horizon
europe the new program uh in place since
this year and horizon 2020 was in place
until 2020 so since 21 and verizon uh
2020 until until 2020 and there are some
projects still from the old program so
let me go to the two programs so on the
horizon europe there's no ongoing
project with russia
um and as i already said any uh
i mean no new contracts will be signed
um
i the commissioner made reference to
some ongoing work which is now on hold
but i cannot go into details
because this is uh covered by
confidentiality because the agreement is
as i said on hold on the horizon 2020
there are
active projects
which involve
78 organizations with russia
on the rise in 2020 2020
these are um so there's 29 organizations
involved in 18 projects
um and but as i said as for the moment
this is reviewed and there will be no
new payments for the moment under this
project so everything is for the moment
on ice but i cannot tell you for how
long this is ongoing we will look into
this very carefully thank you
right
thank you
okay we go back to
ekrem one last time to see if
you can connect
can you hear me yes go ahead yes
yes ah
this time it's not about gas but about
oil the white house spokesman person
jamsaki
i think it was friday or thursday
said that the us is considering how
could the uh iran oil fit in in
minimizing uh eventual uh decision to
cut
the oil imports from russia but the
question is here how much and how far
eventually have gone the toll between
the white house and the commission and
new member states on on minimizing uh
the impact of such all the cuts from
russia
and and and and
seeking the uh
finding the other uh
routes of supply from other countries us
and
the middle east countries as well from
thursday from today where are we with
these talks with
with the white house
i'm afraid i come that we're not going
to give
a day-to-day uh debriefing of our
contacts with the uh with the white
house on all the different aspects of
the of the ukraine crisis as i've said
the president herself in the vip corner
today
uh mentioned specifically that one of
the objectives that the commission was
pursuing
for the european union is
to get rid of our dependence on russian
oil gas
and coal and i've just mentioned in the
answer to the previous question
the ways in which we want to do this one
of them indeed is diversify
our sources of supply
and that is certainly something on which
we are working but i'm not in a position
to give you here further details on
on exactly what is taking place in order
to
ensure that this that this happens
augustine
okay
i have a question on
defense spending and
stability fact
budgetary rules
i apologize if this was already asked
because i joined few minutes late
is commission considering or is this
being debated that
defense spending
from member states should not be
included
into the obligations for budgetary uh
deficit uh
rules
i many countries have announced that
they are going to
increase dramatically their
defense spending thank you
thank you very much well as you know
there is a process when it comes to the
review of disability and growth pact and
this process is uh currently ongoing the
commission has said that it will come
forward with proposals um
in
due time in order for these proposals to
be
implementable in
the near future
and but of course until our proposals
have been tabled we are not going to be
commenting on the work that is going on
inside the commission on
on these
right are there other questions for us
today
i do not see any so thank you very much
and
a reminder tomorrow college meeting in
strasbourg therefore we'll have a
college readout from strasbourg in the
afternoon thank you
you